okay i'm this is going to sound like an
onion story or like a saturday night
live story but this is not satire
after months and months of denying that
russia interfered in our election
donald trump has within a 36-hour period
seemed to admit that russia interfered
in the election
and blamed president obama for not
stopping it this
is just no i don't have cooties you have
cooties this is that defense from the
playground when you're seven
years old trump yesterday posted a
series of tweets
bizarrely accusing barack obama of
exactly what trump is being accused of
now
trump is saying obama colluded with
russia
let's look at the tweets from donald
trump's twitter account where he said
the reason that president obama did
nothing about
russia after being notified by the cia
of meddling
is that he expected clinton would win
and did not want to rock the boat
he didn't choke he colluded or
obstructed
and it did the dems and crooked hillary
no good this defense
is now the defining characteristic of
the new right or the alt-right or the
trump right whatever you want to call it
but hillary did it but obama did it and
what donald trump is saying here
if if you didn't realize this already is
nonsense on multiple levels number one
the obama administration said they
didn't publicize the russian hacks
because they didn't want to taint the
election this was out of respect for the
electoral process
it wasn't uh to to help hillary clinton
it was actually to avoid giving the
impression
that they were trying to help hillary
clinton trump after all
went on and on during the election about
how it was rigged
so obama not announcing the russian
hacking
helped trump so i don't understand why
donald trump would even complain about
that in the first place
i think you just get so tired of being
on the defense for months and months
that you have to
find something to go on the offense with
if you remember after the billy bush
access hollywood tapes came out grabbed
by the [ __ ] trump
brought uh some bill clinton accusers to
the debate like paula jones and
you know it was completely nonsensical
because that had been litigated decades
before but he did it anyway that's
exactly what he's doing and i want to
talk about that in a second
before though i want to mention also
that trump's statement doesn't make
logical sense either
trump says obama colluded or obstructed
by not talking about the russian hacks
with whom was obama supposedly
obstructing or colluding
and that would mean he was obstructing
or colluding to help trump
what is trump even arguing here and also
colluded or
obstructed it's sort of the opposite
right it's obvious that donald trump is
taking language that has been used about
him
and just trying to apply it to other
people if you collude
you're working with someone if you
obstruct
you're working against someone how is it
that oh obama either colluded or
obstructed
well one would be the exact opposite of
the other and then donald trump went on
to say
on twitter the real story is that
president obama did nothing after being
informed in august about russian
meddling with four months looking at
russia
donald trump going on to say under a
magnifying glass
they have zero quote tapes of trump
people colluding
there is no collusion and there is no
obstruction
i should be given an apology it's
ironic and baffling that trump is acting
asking for the apology after he is
accusing others without evidence of
colluding
and obstructing isn't it i think next
he'll be calling for the impeachment of
barack obama because we have to get him
out of office immediately
well what you said earlier is is really
relevant here which is that
unfortunately
a lot of trump supporters are uninformed
and gullible enough to take
take trump at his word here without
knowing what the hell is going on and
just say oh look yeah
trump's accused of collusion and now
obama's accused of collusion trump
accused of obstruction
and now obama is being accused of
obstruction what's really going on here
is that trump is under major pressure
right now
his campaign is under investigation for
possible collusion with the russian
government for possible obstruction
of an investigation into that collusion
trump himself personally under
investigation
and trump is childishly saying i know
you are but what am i
i know you are but what am i and uh
that is going to be unfortunately
effective
there's allegations on one side there's
allegations on the other and he's
trivializing the meaning of these words
that's what donald trump is doing here
if everyone is doing obstruction if
everyone is doing collusion even though
even though i don't know what the hell
it is that donald trump is talking about
then it can't really be that bad trump
is using the terms that have been used
by others regularly
to devalue the terms create generalized
confusion and trivialize their meaning
and i wish it wasn't going to work pat
but if this type of thing didn't work
donald trump wouldn't be president right
now
it works and we should expect that it
will work i mean to people like us this
is seen as completely ludicrous
but it's more trump truth-telling on the
other side yeah it's fake news to even
report on this right that's the
perspective
many discussions about this on our
reddit discussion forum
check it out at davidpakman.com
today's program is made possible in part
by game fly which is sort of like
netflix for video games they've got over
8 000
new and classic games for xbox one xbox
360
ps4 ps3 wii and a bunch of other
platforms
and you can also stream games you don't
even need
a gaming console or a computer because
you can stream
games through your amazon fire stick or
roku box
and then use your mobile phone as the
controller you can play as many games as
you want for one monthly fee
and if you find some games you want to
keep you can buy them for a low
used price never with due dates or late
fees
and our audience can get a 30-day free
trial
at gameflyoffer.com tdps the games are
shipped directly to you
with return envelopes included no
contracts and you can also stream the
games i think i mentioned that
you can also rent games through the
mobile app get a free 30-day trial
for david pakman show viewers and
listeners and support our show
at gameflyoffer.com forward slash
tdps